Speaker 1: Marjorie Taylor GREENE continues
her brutal assault on solar panels,
wind energy, electric vehicles. This is one
of my favorite topics. These right wingers,
I genuinely don't know whether they're this dumb
or they just believe their followers are dumb. But
they are continuing this path of saying electric
vehicles are no good. You can't drive anywhere in
electric vehicles. They don't have enough range.
We don't have enough electrical supply in the grid
to power electric vehicles. Solar power and
wind power are no good and you can't really
do all the things you might want to do in your
home if you have solar or wind power. Here is
Marjorie Taylor GREENE straight up saying, if
you depend on wind turbines and solar panels,
you're not going to be able to have air
conditioning in the summer and you're not going
to be able to run your appliances. Check this out.
Speaker 4: The gentleman.
Unidentified: We're over here
in Georgia. Can we just say.
Speaker 4: Thank God for
your discount refrigerators,
please? I like my refrigerator. I know you
all like yours. Washing machines and dryers
or please God, don't make me scrub clothes in
a bucket and have the hair out on the line.
Why don't you switch over to turbines and
solar panels? I'm going to be really pissed
off about that.
Speaker 1:
This is a real you know, the sun is hot. How could
you possibly cool anything down with solar power?
This is not new. Okay. This is a newer
version of what Donald Trump was going
around saying during his 2020 campaign about
Joe Biden's energy policy. Remember, this will.
Speaker 2: Be no heating in the winter,
no air conditioning in the summer,
and no electricity whenever you want it.
Right now, you haven't made yourself lucky.
You are so lucky, have you? A president?
Unidentified:
And your team is.
Speaker 2: Doing a good job.
Speaker 1: Right. So this is the same
thing they've been pulling for a while.
There's just not enough power in wind and solar
to power anything. If Joe Biden is president,
you won't have heating or cooling. By the way,
we've had heating or cooling under Joe Biden.
I can assure you, you can have everything you
want with solar and wind. I have solar. It runs
my air conditioning all summer and I still
get credits and cashback. It runs my fridge,
it runs my oven. It runs all of the elements of
my bathroom that doesn't actually use electricity.
Those are plumbing. It charges my electric vehicle
and it pays zero each month during the summer.
And I build up credits for winter. Yes, in
winter I use more than the solar generates,
but I've got the credits and the rebates from the
summer and I pay zero for utilities and it's just
solar. Now it is true that right now I
have solar panels, but I can't store that
I don't have a battery system and this
is something that's going to be the next
phase. There are people who have a battery
system so that at night when there's no sun,
you are using your stored electricity. Right
now, the way it works is when I overproduce,
other people get to use the power generated by
my solar panels and then at night I'm getting
power generated elsewhere. But it works out
to where I'm juice generating as much as I use
so far this summer, just running everything
with solar panels. I got $250 in rebates
and I've got about $300 in credit built up with
the electric company to offset my winter heating
when there's less sun. And you might say, well,
what about beautiful gas or oil heat? I mean,
that's super powerful and efficient, right?
At least for heating. We should be using those
things. Now, electric heat pumps are much more
efficient than furnaces, and most heating systems
in the United States are using forced air furnaces
of some kind. They either run on natural gas
or oil or sometimes electricity. And that is much
less efficient than these heat pumps, electric
heat pumps that are there to heat a building. The
heat pump will extract energy from the outdoor air
or from the ground and convert it to heat
from the house. It's much more efficient. So
I don't know whether Marjorie Taylor GREENE
just doesn't know about any of this stuff
or whether she knows, but understands that
she has to keep repeating these things.
I genuinely don't know. I mean, she doesn't strike
me as particularly bright, but they are now on
this really, really hard electric vehicles, bad
solar panels, bad wind power, bad. It's all bad.
It's actually all really good. And the efficiency
that we would achieve if more vehicles switched to
electric and more homes switch to solar and wind
with electric heat pumps and induction cooktops
would be an incredible effect. Now, this
this doesn't mean we excuse industrial
carbon footprints. This is the thing where
people get into, well, if I just stop using
straws or whatever. Yeah, that's very it's pennies
on the dollar and we have to deal with industry.
It must be dealt with. But if the entire country
switched to these more efficient systems,
it wouldn't be the problem. Marjorie Taylor
GREENE is saying it would actually be really good